let's see after the mass extinction of
humanity the life of a teenager raised
alone by a robot changes completely when
she runs into another human who makes
her doubt what she perceived as her
reality so today on cinema recapped i'll
show you i am mother the movie begins
with a facility called the repopulation
facility where we learned that it's been
days after the extinction of humanity in
this place human embryos are stored and
at the moment there are no humans stop
them a machine gets assembled and starts
up a humanoid robot which conceals a
human embryo we see how the humanoid
robot sits down to wait for the embryo
to develop because of the advanced
technology only a few hours pass and the
embryo is ready to be born the robot
takes the baby out of the incubator
cleans her and talks to her tenderly
while holding her top ears pass and the
robot keeps taking care of the baby
feeds her accompanies her while she
begins to take her first steps and
educates her as is she or her mother the
baby grows up learns how to speak and we
see that she's aware of her situation
cause she tells the robot that she does
not want to be human since humans were
the ones who spoiled the world.teacher
robot answers her that humans can't
become great people and that very soon
she will make more humans like her in
order to be a bigger family which makes
the girl very happy the girl becomes a
teenager who is well educated by the
robot since sometimes she can even
repair her robot mother using the
knowledge she got from her on a normal
day in the facilities suddenly
everything turns off even the robot one
so the teenager looks for what caught
the blackout and shortly after she finds
a rodent which is bitten some wires the
girl immediately repairs the wires and
cuts the road into this small container
when the powers are stored the robot
mother wakes up and asks about the
blackout so the teenager answers that it
was caused by the small robot that she
has in the container the robot
immediately burns the animal in the
crematorium since it came from outside
and could bring an illness to the
teenager the teenager is not happy with
the set so she comments that perhaps the
exterior is now habitable but the robot
replies that it's unlikely and
apologizes for what happened to the
rodents
the girl reflects on what happened and
the robot asks what is happening to her
so she answers that perhaps she could be
wrong and that could be life out there
which the robot refuses outright and
reaffirms that the calculations have
never been wrong from one moment to
another the light begins to fail again
and in an attempt to discover what is
causing it the girl hears noises outside
and decides to come closer and wears a
special suit to go out without the
consent of her mother
shortly before leaving the noise gets
closer and the girl discovers that it
comes from a strange woman from the
outside who's badly injured and asks for
help she lets her enter the first gate
but tells her that she must wait there
since when she opened the gate the
metallic mother got alarmed and will
come soon a teenager fearful of what her
mother can do decides to hide the woman
from her and cure her in private
shortly after she manages to slip away
from her mother so she can help the
stranger this woman realizes that what
the teenager calls mother is actually an
android and tells the young woman that
she needs to get out of there since an
android was the one who shot her outside
the mother locates them and immediately
the stranger begins to shoot her but the
robot easily avails the bullets and
submits the stranger so the teenager
asks her to cure her since she is badly
injured and scared the mother does not
like this that decides to help her
however the stranger is scared and does
not let the mother touch her therefore
the robot leaves her alone so that she
can heal herself but she locks her up
for everyone's safety after what
happened mother and daughter have a talk
and a young woman asks her mother for
explanations about the androids being
dangerous and she answers her that she
only lied a little for her safety but
that she does not have to be scared
since she has never heard her the robot
also tells her that perhaps there are
more survivors out there and that they
have to make the stranger cooperate in
order to help the mum for this reason
the young woman tries to chat and make
the stranger cooperate but she replies
that she does not trust the androids and
that the young woman shouldn't either
the teenager replies that her mother is
not like that that she has always taken
care of her but the stranger tells her
that soon she would not
shortly after the woman's health gets
worse so mother and daughter have to
intervene or she will die but even in
her state the woman refuses to be cured
by the robot so the young woman decides
to do the operation the woman accepts
but with a certain level of distrust and
asks not to be anesthetized and that the
robot does not approach either
the operation is a complete success and
the robot congratulates her daughter for
such achievement the woman loses
consciousness but she's stable when she
wakes up after the operation she sees
the young woman who was taking care of
her while she was sleeping she tells her
that she has done a lot for her so she's
grateful after chatting for a few
moments the woman confides that there
are several humans living in the mines
but she only tells the young woman
secretly since she still mistrusts the
robot
the woman invites the young woman to
accompany her to the mind since neither
of them belongs there at that precise
moment the robotic mother arrives and
interrupts the conversation asking her
daughter to leave because she has other
duties once outside the stranger's room
the robot tells her daughter that the
woman has not been entirely sincere
since the bullet they extracted in the
operation is from a human weapon and not
an android one as she said then the
young woman is thoughtful and in turn
the robot asks her for details of the
conversation she had with the strange
woman and the girl comments that she has
not said anything which is a lie we see
that mother and daughter continue with
their normal lives the young woman
approves a test easily so the robot mom
gives her the right to choose her first
brother in other words she chooses the
next embryo that will be incubated so
that the family grows the young woman
gets excited because she will soon have
a little brother after receiving the
news the teenager decides to go with the
woman and ask her for an explanation
regarding the bullet which the woman
denies and comments that the robot is
lying to her at this point the young
woman cannot even sleep well since she
does not know what is happening who's
telling her the truth and who is lying
so she decides to steal the access key
from her mother and investigate the
bullets to see if them told the truth
when investigating the things protected
by her mother she finds the bullet they
extracted and compares it with the one
from the stranger's weapon and realizes
that indeed the bullets were not the
same so the woman was telling the truth
but things get even worse cause him in
the private things of her robotic mother
she finds some strange files with the
numbering of some empty spaces where
there were embryos before the young
woman feels more and more confused and
continues to investigate when she opens
the files she finds photos of other
girls that according to the files for
field projects continuing to investigate
the archives she ends up verifying that
the so-called field projects ended up
being incinerated into crematory
movements then she decides to check that
and indeed there were human remains of
girls in the crematoriums the teenager
goes with the woman and lets her know
that she was right and she answers that
they must leave the place immediately
but the young woman refuses since she
wants to wait for her brother who will
be born soon the next day the young
woman is collecting the things that she
thinks are necessary for her escape but
her mother caught her so the young woman
makes excuses for her behavior and the
robot notices she's nervous
from one moment to another the mother
locks her up in the room and goes to
where the strange woman is and tells her
that she knows everything since she
recorded them when they planned their
escape she wants more details of the
humans in the caves but she refuses to
give her information about them and then
the woman waits for the right moment to
jump on the robot and try to kill her
but she gets quickly subdued by the
robot meanwhile the young woman manages
to escape and turns on the alarm to
distract the robot so she can leave with
the woman from that dangerous place when
they get together the woman says they
must leave immediately and come back for
her brother and the embryo slater they
decide to go out but they cannot open
the door since it's controlled by the
robotic mother at that moment the robot
arrives and tries to convince her to
author to regret her actions the woman
see no more escape decides to take the
teenager hostage to force the mother to
open the door the mother has no
alternative so she opens the door and
lets them out
outside they have a little discussion
about the improvised act that the woman
had to perform in order to leave but
after a bad moment their lacks and start
their way to the mines shortly after
drone passes over them one much larger
compared to the robot mother they have
to run towards some corn crops where
they can hide
a teenager asks the woman what are all
those crops and those machines that are
growing them to which she replies that
they arrived about six months ago and
since then the air quality has improved
other way to the mines they pass through
several abandoned places that were
inhabited by people in the past after
walking for a long time they both arrive
at a beach where the woman enters the
medal wagon where the teenager asks her
where the others are and she answers
that they are in a kind of tongues but
that she separated from them a long time
ago the woman explains that such place
was dangerous since very bad things
happened because of the hunger and fear
they had so that's why she left they
argue again and the teenager decides to
come back for her brother when she gets
home or at least what it was a few days
ago she's welcome at the door by a few
dozen androids suing straight at her
chest ready to shoot her the teenager
just raises her hands and says i just
want to talk to my mother so the
androids get aside and she manages to
enter taking an axe and preparing for
whatever is going to happen the mother
was waiting for her with her brother in
her huge metallic arms the teenager
takes her brother in her arms but then
she runs and closed the door so that her
mother would be trapped between the
doors then the teenager asks her to stop
everything by threatening her with a
weapon since the androids outside try to
enter by force and the mother replies
that those androids actually share the
same conscience some kind of artificial
intelligence that handles everything
even the machines that grow plants
outside she also confesses that she was
the one who had to intervene in the
extinction of humans to be able to
recreate and improve them since the
humans were very destructive that is why
she started her embryo project
the teenager cries and asks her mother
to let her recreate the world to trust
her and after a moment of reflection her
mother decides to give it a chance and
asks her to kill her the sudden change
of camera we see how one of the androids
arrives at the metal box where the woman
that the teenager left behind lives and
the robot comments it was not a
coincidence that you have survived so
long unlike the others what happened is
that you had a mission until now and he
closes the door locking himself with the
woman inside the metal wagon back with
the teenager we see how she goes to the
room where the embryos are and she is
determined to create the new world the
end
if you liked the video please leave a
like and subscribe to continue receiving
the recaps of the best sci-fi movies i
hope you are doing well and i'll see you
in the next video bye